what's like another establishment that's
like very specific to like japanese
nightlife because i like to think that
like the
karaoke nightlife i mean karaoke
nightlife here has just got it
done like it's it's it's the perfect
it's the perfect kind of place for
karaoke because i didn't realize until
recently but like the karaoke in japan
is so much different to the perception
of karaoke and western countries because
i remember
when uh yumi and felix
when we took felix to a karaoke for the
first time he didn't want to go
yeah he was kind of like oh karaoke
cringe that sounds cringe because i
think in his mind
his idea of karaoke is an open bar
karaoke yeah
which i think a lot of people think i
think a lot of people think because in
japan i feel like
after the izakaya you know or after
going to a pub in england the the
president is
after the pub you basically go clubbing
there's no other place to go but in
in japan or go home and watch yeah yeah
exactly right
but in japan you can just go to karaoke
and just continue the sesh there
yeah also hang out with your mates and
sing a bunch of songs as well it's all
you can drink it
again it's all you can drink everywhere
you go in japan you can get all you can
drink
it's [ __ ] great it's all you can
drink and the karaoke establishment is
open 24 hours yeah
which is just like a power move although
i swear like whichever brand is offering
because not all of them do all you can
drink and some of them do it for like
way more expensive than others oh yeah i
never know which [ __ ] one it is so i
just walk in and i'm like please be the
cheaper well that's like yeah that's the
thing though like you have to kind of go
around to each
brand of karaoke chain yeah and kind of
be like okay
this is the cheapest one for all you can
drink this is the most expensive one for
you can drink so you have to kind of be
like okay do i
take value over price or price of a
value
yeah right because you know that if you
go to the cheap ones the food is
probably going to be like not that great
because like i've never like my entire
life i've never really enjoyed karaoke
until i
experienced karaoke in japan right
because it's not only it's not only like
having having a private room so to
explain japanese karaoke you have this
private room
where you can just sing as many songs as
you like that you choose
um there's no one watching you apart
from your own mates and you can just
have fun and sing whatever the hell you
want in the book
they also have like every single like
western song so yeah yeah yeah so
like they have a selection that is like
the eclipses
everywhere else i've been to they have
like english songs chinese songs korean
songs and obviously japanese
anime songs yeah i was about to say
man singing singing anime songs while
you're playing as a weeb
that was like i remember my first
experience was with joey and it was like
one of the funnest experience ever
it's like seeing that list of all the
anime songs it's like opening pandora's
box
you're like which one do i sing
it's like and then the moment he
selected [ __ ] tell me why by the pen
pals i was just like
yeah okay the original the original
berserk with the
shittiest guitar riff in existence i'm
like yeah hell yeah
like it's already bad in the original
but then the karaoke version was like oh
this is so much worse but it's so much
better lasted at 3am we [ __ ]
destroyed that song more than it already
destroyed itself
[Laughter]
for a while i think it's back open
though right yeah from what i understand
yeah yeah but
it's hard to get in that mood you know
yeah i know i know it's like
i don't know like i feel now that we've
all kind of been established here
it's like become a little bit more
difficult to just be like hey you want
to stay up till like 4am to go to
karaoke
maybe because i get i go to bed at like
12 now i think i get really [ __ ]
tired earlier
like my sleep schedule's a lot healthier
now okay to explain another thing about
japanese drinking culture is that
you have this ticking clock and it's
called the last train
and if you missed the last train you're
staying out until 5am
there's there's no there's basically no
in between either you choose to go home
at like what like
11 12 11 12 11 11 30
which to me is like if it was just one
hour later or like two hours later it
would be perfect
because after about one o'clock i'd be
like okay i've had my fun this is this
is cool
i'm gonna catch the last train now but
like having to choose between going out
at uh like 11 30 when you're just about
getting to that point of drunkness that
you just want to keep
going to staying up till 5 00 5 a.m
which we've done it several times
yeah and every time i just feel more
dead inside like
is nothing worse i think i think the
only thing that is worse than
going home while you're buzzed at 11 p.m
is
catching that first train at 4 30. just
like [ __ ] like
oh my god it's like sunny outside and
then like this businessman next to you
and you're clearly a [ __ ] mess
you just turn into [ __ ] vampires
i [ __ ] fell asleep one time and
missed my stop by like an
hour i woke up at like 6am like in like
so [ __ ] northern like the end of the
line right yeah yeah i was like an hour
from like i think i was like an hour and
a half from tokyo yeah yeah yeah
that's how far i'd gone i was like get
back and i was so
[ __ ] done yeah i was it was like 6 30
a.m when i realized and i was like
no so i wanted to sleep
yeah i mean that's the tough thing man i
mean
that's the thing like back when i was
like still single
and like kind of going out and doing a
lot more of like the 4am 5am stuff
it would be a little bit easier because
you know say like
a couple of my friends would be like
it'd be like you know one or two a.m and
be like uh
maybe we shouldn't continue anymore it
was really easy because you could just
go to a manga cafe
and just book a [ __ ] room for like
two three hours just [ __ ] sleep in
there until the first train
and that [ __ ] but we haven't done that
we should do that more often
instead of just being like let's let's
uh let's call up a taxi and spend a
hundred bucks to get home
i've always known that you can do the
manga cafes i just don't want to have
that conversation at 3am smashed
some japanese doodrum like uh manga
uh
every single time it's been like i'll
just wait till 5am i'll just yeah
we should just do that from now on yeah
if we're having like a boys now we just
be like i don't want something because
sometimes
i don't want to spend a hundred bucks to
[ __ ] go you know we're all going back
the same way it's time you split it
three ways i mean yeah
yeah still it's like you still feel like
[ __ ]
[Music]
the clown is taking over